our main story tonight concerns food
whether you're a vegan a carnivore or
somewhere in between all of it is either
ripped from its home or dies screaming
food is fun specifically we're going to
talk about food safety it is a vital
component of Public Health as
demonstrated by this old PSA about a
military base having to deal with an
outbreak of salmonella at midnight about
40 of us in the duty section Got A light
meal it was just about this time that
things were beginning to
happen it began like this at first a few
of the men who weren't in the duty
section got
sick and it got steadily worse vomiting
abdominal pains and diarrhea it was hard
to tell which caused the most trouble
except it isn't because diarrhea causes
the most trouble there is just no doubt
about that if you had to choose between
those three symptoms diarrhea is dead
last
every single time abdominal pains not
fun but also grow up sometimes your
tummy hurts that's life vomiting awful
but at least you can somewhat control
the trajectory it is possible to
daintily vomit in public but there is
absolutely no way to retain any shred of
dignity once you have shat yourself it
is game over you can't come back from
that you're basically an animal you live
at the zoo
now odar you've probably experienced
getting sick from food at some point in
your life it happens a lot every year an
estimated 46 million Americans are
sickened by food born illnesses and of
them 128,000 are hospitalized and about
3,000 die now obviously it is in the
public interest to try and prevent any
of that from happening which is why so
often you'll turn on the TV and see
stories like these craft hins has
voluntarily recalled 7,000 cases of Taco
Bell salsa cono mild cheese dip out of
botulism concern an expanded recall of
peaches linked to a salmonella outbreak
several GIF peanut butter products are
being pulled from the shelves stores
cannot sell this cereal legally because
of this recall so if you have the honey
smacks in your pantry please throw it
out okay so a couple of things there on
the first one honestly I'd always
assumed that all Taco Bell jard products
could give you botulism you want the
spice you roll the dice everyone
understands that and as for throw out
your honey smacks that's pretty good
advice even when there's not a recall
because look look at this look like
maggots glazed with sugar and that's
without getting into the mascot who is
this serial mascots are supposed to be
Charming whether they're a cultural
stereotype that this accent doesn't get
to enjoy or an inappropriately sexy
Tiger but this this is nothing why does
your shirt say dig him dig what the
honey smacks absolutely not you
amphibian
pervert and look when you see stories
like those you would assume that the
government is constantly on the lookout
for potentially dangerous food but it's
become increasingly clear that our food
safety system in particular the Food and
Drug Administration which oversees most
of it has some serious shortcomings in
2016 an audit done by the agency itself
found unacceptable delays in getting
dangerous food off the shells finding
that in 30 recalls it took an average of
57 days from when the FDA was notified
and the author of that report
acknowledged that was a big problem
unless you get all the product off the
shelf people still at risk if you were
playing Russian roulette you took all
the bullets out of the gun and you put
it to your head there's no risk but if
there's still a couple of bullets left
in there you're still playing Russian
roulette aren't you wow that is an
alarmingly apt metaphor for the current
safety of our food supply although real
quick if you are playing Russian
roulette and you take all the bullets
out of the gun for what it's worth you
are no longer playing Russian roulette
you're in a community theater production
of the seagull I had to leave at
intermission but you were so good good
and you might remember the FDA
shortcomings were badly exposed last
year when Abbott a company that makes
40% of this country's baby formula shut
down its Factory over serious safety
violations violations that the FDA
clearly should have acted on much sooner
a sign of trouble came last September in
a report to the FDA an infant who became
ill with a rare bacterial infection had
consumed formula made at the Abbott
plant in October an Abbot whistle sent
FDA officials this 34-page document
alleging that LAX practices including
regulatory violations were consistently
overlooked it wasn't until January 31st
that the FDA sent a team to the abbit
facility to investigate there they found
evidence of bacteria in the powdered
infant formula environment that can be
deadly to infants it's true the FDA took
four months from their first sign
something was wrong to do a follow-up
inspection and at that point at least
four babies have been hospitalized and
two died even internal FDA report
afterwards concluded that the agency had
systemic vulnerabilities and a much more
scathing outside audit faltered them for
lack of communication and engagement
across the agency but the truth is
scathing report finds fault with the FDA
is just not a new story it has happened
again and again and again you can find
similar reports in 2010 1991 and even
this one from back in
1969 the American Consumer is surrounded
by an arsenal of products which can kill
or maim him and the Food and Drug
Administration has neither the money nor
the authority to do much about it that's
the gist of a confidential report
prepared by seven senior members of the
FDA that is Walter kronite flagging the
state of the FDA is a serious problem
half a century ago and if something that
he reported on is still an issue you
know you've got a problem I'm just
saying if JFK was still regularly
getting shot in Dallas you'd really hope
somebody would have done something about
it by now but given that we've known the
way the FDA regulates food is some
version of for decades tonight
let's talk about exactly why that is and
why it's been so hard to fix and let's
start with the fact that despite the FDA
standing for Food and Drug
Administration the two parts of that are
not given remotely equal weight drugs
are prioritized heavily FDA
Commissioners almost always come from
the medical side and have almost no
experience with food issues and
apparently it's a long running joke
among FDA officials that the F in FDA is
silent in fact its own staff including
some FDA Commissioners have been known
to slip up and call it the Federal Drug
Administration and come on there's only
two things to remember in the name Food
and Drugs if you need a helpful
pneumonic for it just remember this
simple phrase Food and Drugs it's to
words also interestingly the FDA doesn't
actually oversee the safety of all food
in the US it oversees around 80% of it
but the remaining 20% largely falls
under the usda's food safety and
inspection service and the division of
responsibilities can get maddeningly
complicated while broadly the USDA
oversees beef poultry and some egg
products and the FDA oversees the rest
in practice where the exact lines get
drawn can get
ridiculous take a look at this beef
broth made in a plant regulated by the
USDA which inspects every day but
chicken broth made in a plant regulated
by the FDA which is inspected once every
5 years in the frozen food aisle cheese
pizza is regulated by the FDA pepperoni
pizza well that's the USDA the fish well
that's FDA except one catfish that's
USDA yeah it's pretty confusing it can
be very difficult to guess which agency
of overseas which kinds of food for
example eggs in their shells FDA eggs
processed into egg products USDA the
feed that egg laying hens eat FDA again
open-faced meat sandwich USDA but closed
face meat sandwich that's FDA and as you
know if you make a half cheese half
pepperoni pizza and then put an egg on
top the whole government actually
explodes and the thing is that fractured
structure can create a lot of cracks for
problems to fall into then there are the
funding issues because despite the fact
that the FDA overseas remember 80% off
food they and the USDA receive close to
the same amount of funding for food
safety oversight meaning the FDA
essentially has to make the same budget
go four times as far on top of that the
fda's job is actually much more complex
because while the usda's work is
concentrated in large Meat Processing
plants of which we have relatively few
around 800 the fda's perview includes
about 35,000 produce Farms 300,000
restaurant chain establishments 10 a
half th000 vending machine operators and
roughly 275,000 food processing
facilities more than half of which are
overseas very basically the FDA is
spread extremely thin and the USDA isn't
and this discrepancy actually helps to
explain a shocking fact that came to
light after that baby formula incident
last year regarding the size of the FDA
team that is tasked with overseeing
those particular factories there's a
total of nine people who are focused on
infant formula at the FDA in the budget
we got an additional four people
allocated last year but we're going to
need more than that that's true the
entire department overseeing infant
formula was just nine people that is
just not enough for context this show
has four interns and we need all of them
but the stakes of their jobs are just
not nearly as high their only life or
death duty is making sure that Mr
nutterbutter never gets out of his cage
oh oh everybody stay
incredibly
still so clearly some of the fda's
issues come from without in how it's
structured and funded but some of his
problems come from within like the fact
that even by government standards it has
an infamously slow bureaucracy take for
instance this very specific announcement
that they made at the end of 2020 a
shakeup for French dressing fans the
Food and Drug Administration is
proposing removing ingredient
requirements for the salad dressing at
the request of the association for
dressings and sauces right now dressing
must include vinegar oil and lemon or
lime in order to be called French now I
know that was about an FDA ruling but
the only thing that I'm thinking about
after watching that clip is the
association for dressings and sauces I
now want to know everything about them
I'm guessing Ranch and barbecue sauce of
the heavyweights there Mayo 2 obviously
and then there's probably turmoil over
the hot young newcomers truffle ketchup
Green Goddess dressing all the flashy
stuff I get it but who do you think the
black sheep of the organization are
werer maybe some of the more up
mustards this is the only thing I'm
interested in talking about now just
know anytime I'm talking about something
else 90% of my brain is still focused on
the association for dressings and
sources but the point of showing you
that clip is that the FDA made that
announcement at the end of 2020 after my
new favorite trade group asked him to do
something about the definition of friend
stressing back in and this is true
1998 and when they announced the
decision they didn't even explain why it
took them more than two decades spanning
1 1911 and the dissolution of the Spice
Girls to arrive at that decision but all
of this dysfunction has real
consequences because it's not just baby
formula or honey smacks that can cause
illness one of the biggest
vulnerabilities in our current system
actually has to do with leafy greens
they are overseen by the FDA and are a
major source of food contamination and
one of the key reasons for that is that
large industrial Farms have become more
common with livestock raised extremely
close to where crops are being grown and
sometimes even sharing a water source
and that as this expert explains can be
a real issue how we raise animals can
fuel the growth of these bugs so if we
crowd the animals together and you have
one that's carrying a really bad
pathogen like eoli 157 then they can
poop those bacteria out
and then the from the
cattle washes off into the into the
streams or into canals irrigation
canals and then those can be used to
water these
plants you have this distribution system
for these pathogens from animals to
produce now there are a lot of excellent
production choices in that documentary
including decides to both cinematically
shoot a cow and allow someone
to say the word I support that
choice you can keep your little
pleasantries like feces and manure but
it's cow call it what it is we know
it when we see it if not always when we
eat it but the point is that can go
from the animals into water which is
then sprayed directly onto the lettuce
and given the growth in boxed and bagged
salads just one head of contaminated
lettuce can get spread out across a lot
of people and while with meat you can
kill off a lot of the pathogens simply
through the act of cooking it with
produce like leafy greens your options
are significantly more limited rinsing
fruits and vegetables is always a good
idea but Health experts say ecoi isn't
easily washed away I had a professor who
used to say you can't sterilize lettuce
with a blowtorch wow that is a striking
thing for your professor to have said to
you although to be fair it's technically
not true because you obviously can
sterilized lettuce with a blowtorch and
the reason I know that is just watch
me
I'm not saying this is a good idea or
that it tastes good afterwards I'm just
saying you clearly can sterilize lettuce
with a blow touch okay facts
matter and all of
this all of this would make you hope
that our produce is as thoroughly
inspected as our beef but the opposite
is the case because while there are over
7,000 workers overseeing beef for the
USDA there are only 614 FDA fielders
investigators responsible for leafy
greens and I would say that this is a
disaster waiting to happen except it
already has happened and repeatedly in
2018 an ecoli outbreak in leafy greens
sickened 240 people and killed five
across 36 States later that same fall a
different eoli outbreak hit again in
leafy greens but the FDA was so tied up
dealing with the first one that an FDA
executive wrote to his colleagues I have
no resources to deploy and he a little
disconcerting that messages from a
modern Public Health Department sound a
lot like missives from the Civil
War and as this food safety expert
explains all of that leads to a truly
striking truth when you eat a hamburger
the the most dangerous part of that is
not the burger it's going to be the
onion lettuce and the tomatoes that's
not great to hear is it partly because I
don't want to live in a world where
lettuce onion and tomatoes are dangerous
but also because I don't want live in a
world where going to Panera is edgy
Panera is and should always be a milk
toast Suburban destination where women
in their 50s Gossip Girls in their teens
gossip and one very old man eat a bagel
over the course of three hours Panera
should not be edgy but as the FDA seems
to have turned a Greek salad into a
loaded gun I guess it is now so
by this point it should be clear a
massive overhaul is needed here and you
should know overhauls in food safety can
happen it happened to the USDA 30 years
ago after undercooked hamburgers at Jack
In The Box restaurants led to one of the
worst ecoli outbreaks in US history four
children died during that something that
just as a side note Jack in the Box
Executives at the time could have
handled with a little more tacted the
company's President says Jack in the Box
will pay all medical expenses for those
who got sick and he urged customers to
come back to avert another blow to the
company and that second
tragedy would be a loss of jobs that is
a shitty response also how is it the
customer's responsibility to keep your
employees from losing their jobs if we
accidentally killed four people during
one of our multiple stupid
explosions I wouldn't be begging you to
keep watching our show I'd be getting
sent to prison except I'm just kidding
rich white celebrities don't go to
prison Felicity Huffman took one for the
whole team so now we're Square the point
is after jacking the box there was a
public public outcry prompting a major
overhaul to the USDA and the thing is
the FDA almost had a similar moment back
in the late Arts there were a series of
horrific outbreaks in peanut butter
spinach and other foods and in response
Congress passed the food safety
modernization act which gave the FDA
sweeping new powers to regulate food and
at the time everyone thought that this
was a pretty big deal today President
Obama signs a bill for the first major
overhaul of the US food safety system in
almost a century will give the Food and
Drug Administration new powers to force
mandatory recalls when food borne
illness or other hazards are found in
the US food supply if this law is a huge
success a lot of that success is going
to be invisible you are not going to be
seeing as many people sick yeah it
sounded great except if all of that had
actually happened I wouldn't be doing
this story right now would I we'd be
back to our regularly scheduled
programming of hamster loneliness or I
don't know trout gout spoiler
alert is more common you think and
Congress refuses to act there were just
two small problems though with the food
safety modernization act first we didn't
fund the FDA to do all the new things
that we just asked it to do and second
the agency was still hamstrung by its
glacial bureaucracy for instance the law
mandated that the FDA come up with a
standard for water being used in
agriculture basically a way to keep your
salad from getting lightly misted with
microscopic cow the problem is it's
12 years later and it still hasn't
produced a final rule they did in
December 2021 unveil a proposed rule but
it had some major problems including the
fact that it didn't mandate any testing
instead it asked producer Growers to
identify and address their own potential
hazards which is clearly less of a water
standard and more of a self-graded water
quiz and well it would be great if
businesses could be trusted to keep
themselves in check that's not generally
how things go for a good example of this
look at literally any business and look
some people might argue that the FDA
simply needs to be funded better and
that its lines of authority need to be
clearer and to be fair there has been
some recent progress there just last
month they established a new role at the
agency so one person could be in charge
of the fda's entire food safety program
it's a bit incredible that that role
didn't exist until just now but still I
will take it the problem is though
history strongly suggests that it won't
be nearly enough a much Bolder plan
would be to actually break the FDA up
completely and in doing so create a new
agency solely devoted to food now that's
a big move and want likely to face
significant resistance and it would need
to be done very carefully but I would
argue it might be worth it so many
experts we talked to for this story said
that if we were to build a food safety
system from scratch it would look
nothing like the fractured system that
we have today and the fact is under the
system that we have right now future
outbreaks aren't just possible they're
absolutely inevitable and I for one do
not want to live in a world where the
only 100% safe way to prepare a very
very basic
salad is
this